yo
come on you got it oh no
oh dang you can do it you're good you
have health insurance
flee russian spies national security
they made it nice
[Music]
what oh that okay
all righty oh my god he saw right
through that
that's coming off
yo i do it taskmaster is a woman
i call it
creepy creepy broken eye vader thing
going on here
chip oh boy
oh my god i think they're going to love
this
[Applause]
oh my god every time she shows up
joy fills my heart and she's a recruit
we're getting we're getting our
thunderbolts baby oh boy oh boy
it's about to go down welcome back to
new rock stars black widow marks marvel
studios return to feature films for the
first time in two years
but was it worth the wait what was the
idea behind taskmaster and val
in this movie and what the hell did
happen in budapest
exactly well this is a special bonus
episode
of inside marvel where we are talking
all about black widow and now again
we're going to be discussing some
spoilers from the film as we you know
posted
the very beginning of this so we highly
encourage you to watch it if you haven't
already it's absolutely worth a watch
i'm eric voss answering your biggest
questions about black widow with
mt how you doing hey i'm feeling good
it's i'm finally glad that we actually
get to see this movie after so long
i know i am too i am too uh i overall uh
very much enjoyed this
i we have some thoughts about it we're
gonna get to all of it in this episode
and you might have had some questions
coming out of it but we want to start
with a quick
plot summary against spoilers mt take it
away all right so yes in ohio 1995 young
natasha romanov lives with a family
of undercover russian spies including
people posing as her sister yelena her
father alexi and her mother molina and
they steal a file from shields north
institute and flee
to cuba where drakov takes the girls
into the red room where this north
institute data is used to chemically
program
young women into assassins which is not
nice to do to young women
uh and then after some epic opening
titles set to a cover of nirvana smells
like teen spirit it's a
pretty cool imagery there uh yes we find
ourselves in 2016 where natasha flees
thunderbolt ross
after the events of civil war and elena
on her own mission morocco gets exposed
to a chemical that frees her from that
mind control
and she sends natasha more antidote
vials in her norway safe house
where taskmaster attacks but natasha is
able to get away and she meets elena
back in budapest where they are attacked
by other widows and by taskmaster
and natasha recalls their past mission
in budapest with hawkeye
that was to kill dracov alongside his
daughter that's how they found out where
drakoff was
but apparently that failed so they
decide to find drakov's hidden red room
base wherever that is and kill him they
break out of russian prison alexi
and they meet up on melina's pig farm
and they argue
that molina has already called them into
the red room
yes and they're all taken to the red
room a hidden floating base
up in the sky you'll never see it
because it's it's hidden it's just
behind a big cloud
and a molina greets drakov but she and
natasha had swapped identities
mission impossible style which i love i
love a good face
reveal it's not like the space mask
reveals okay it's great yeah
but the bigger reveal here is that
taskmaster is revealed to be drakov's
daughter
antonia who's still alive i don't know
how but she's still alive
it's the worst worst planned explosion
ever
for real like it was cl wow how do you
miss how do you miss a little girl i
don't understand
and they free the widows crash the red
room kill drakov liberate and subdue
antonia
and go their separate ways all in a
matter of what two and a half hours
a lot of happens in this movie and
natasha heads off of course at the end
to join cap and to free all the other
avengers in the raft
um after being arrested by tony stark
yep and
in a post-credits scene set after
avengers end game
elena mourns at natasha's grave we think
it's in ohio but then
is greeted by val julie louise
from uh the falcon the winter soldier
with her next target being
clint barton hawkeye the most dangerous
avenger
yeah i know she weirdly blames hawkeye
for
natasha's death and weirdly knows about
what happened on vermeer
but my whole breakdown of that
post-credits scene and how it ties into
the thunderbolts and the hawkeye disney
plus series
is already on the channel you can watch
it along with my big old breakdown of
all the easter eggs in the movie
but here since hawkeye was really the
unseen archer in the room of this film
we want to explore what really happened
in budapest
what the whole timeline was with
natasha's defection
from the red room organization to
joining uh shield
which uh really was like a burning mcu
question that this movie i believe only
half
answered but before we get to that we've
got some black widow-inspired merch
dropping at newrockstarsmerch.com all
throughout this weekend there's a
really fun russian nesting doll design
with the family
members of black widow being uh you know
of decreasing doll size i love it uh
i'm really excited to grab one of these
so make sure to get your hands on that
we also have our newest latest obsession
shirt with a play
on the classic hourglass black widow
logo black widow
the red deep this one will have a super
limited supply so you got to snap it up
real quick
yes um like it'll be a collector's item
like seven months time they'll be worth
a million dollars a pop
so oh yeah quick um now there will be
other shirts sticker and merch designs
dropped over the next few days while
you're there check out our loki'd
collection which
just released this great loki gator polo
shirt with the little hearts on it
amazing i will be wearing that to pursue
my glorious purpose whatever that ends
up being from now on
uh so buying a shirt or a hat or a
hoodie is one of the best ways that you
can support us here at new rock stars so
see all the merch options at new york
source merch.com but uh mt kickers off
what is uh what is our
big question coming out of black widow
yeah i feel like the first question that
we need to ask
here is what really happened in budapest
like why did this movie
leave most of it like pretty much all of
it honestly off-screen
yes uh so really that mystery of what
happened in budapest was what excited
many fans looking ahead at this movie
like there was that line in 2012's
avengers where natasha and hawkeye
had that memorable exchange while they
were having that shootout with the
chitauri
saying it was like budapest all over
again and clint said you and i remember
budapest very differently
um and then uh obviously marvel thought
it's a big deal because an end game
clint said as they were blasting off to
vormir we are a long way from budapest
uh and now this movie shows natasha
returning to her budapest safe house in
2016 which was years
after that incident with hawkeye and it
suggested that that incident
took place sometime between the mid
2000s and 2011 because natasha was still
a kid in 1995
and uh would have needed to be old
enough to be an assassin finally leaving
the red room program
and by 2011 she was already working for
nick fury under shield
so uh natasha says that her budapest
mission was the final step
of her defection to shield and it was to
assassinate drakov
which she did or tried to by tracking
his daughter antonia
and we see that building explode but
really in the reflection of a car window
and it was suggested that there was some
shootout that left
arrow holes in natasha's safe house and
that natasha and clint
hid in a metro station air vent for
several days
and that is all this movie tells us
about budapest
uh in what way was that like fighting
shitari in new york
or you know was that just the joke of
clint's response that this is not at all
like what we went through yeah it was
just really weird that the way they
handled it because like we were all sort
of expecting to see the scene like a
flashback seed
of budapest with like maybe uh a hawkeye
cameo and like just getting that whole
like maybe you de-aged a bit with that
de-aging technology and like all that
stuff but like
it was just a conversation which i it's
fine i guess but like
it sort of just didn't really just
happen
in this movie it didn't it didn't and it
it
it gave us enough for the context of
this uh black widow film um but it also
makes me wonder empty maybe this
backstory could be explored
in a show that jimmy render is actually
going to be in hawkeye on disney plus
especially now that elena belova is
returning in that show
is confirmed so uh do we think that we
might
get more answers about budapest in in
hawkeye
um definitely i would hope so um because
again they didn't really show us a lot
here and i think that marvel studios
hopefully knows that there is like a
real demand
for like those events in budapest so
like
we might not get a full flashback but i
i feel that maybe
uh clinton will probably give um yelling
them some more details as to what
happened in budapest as you know elena
was in the
in the same room as like hey what are
all these things this is a very curious
event that just happened
so please tell me more after i tried to
kill you and and now we're mates
what i found interesting about those
arrow holes in the safe houses they're
all
in the same place making it seem like
did hawkeye at first try to assassinate
natasha when he met her
like did he follow her to budapest and
maybe they spent several weeks in
budapest of like
clint like trying to get to her kind of
a mr mrs smith sort of thing
and then like after he had her he just
talked to her he tried to convert her
and then over the course of that time
together she's like okay you know what
you're right and i can prove my loyalty
by killing this drakov
i guess i don't know that's probably not
how deprogramming works that's a bit
rushed
right to say that it all happened over a
month period of time in budapest that
would be
quite a before midnight between those
two
before but not for it all to go down
then but no i really i really really dig
that mr mrs smith idea of just like you
know
hawkeye going after her and just she's
just like dodging hawkeye then they
finally meet
i would love to see that movie that
would be a great movie i mean that's why
i hope we get some kind of flashback i'm
not saying
scarlett johansson is a huge actress i
don't know if she's gonna you know cameo
in the hawkeye series the fact that they
have florence pew who's gonna appear in
that is already a pretty big get for
them
i don't know if they have the budget to
also afford a scarlet cameo but
we have a lot more questions we want to
talk about with like taskmaster all the
other things you might have questions
about coming out of this movie but first
we want to thank someone who helped us
make this episode
if you are like me and you've been
obsessively watching and re-watching
scenes to try to pick up on all the
missable details and everything that we
cover
like all the dots on that red room map
you um might also be getting headaches
in some digital eye strain well blue
blocks is here to help
their uh blue light computer glasses are
great to use during the day when
you're working with screens under
artificial light like we are been a big
help for me
blue blocks are made in optics
laboratories in australia with
science-backed technology
tested to ensure they work unlike other
blue light glasses companies
their glasses come in non-prescription
but also prescription and reading
options
they have glasses for every need blue
light for helping with digital eye
strain summer glow for helping with low
mood and migraines
and sleep plus for improving your sleep
blue blocks also has
other amazing products such as low blue
light bulbs
red light therapy devices and 100
blackout sleep masks
all backed by science blue blocks ship
worldwide in rapid time and has easy
returns and exchanges so go to
blueblocks.com
marvel and use our coupon code marvel to
save 20 percent
that's blueblox.com b-l-u-b-l-o-x
dot com slash marvel and use coupon code
marvel
all right empty uh next question why did
black widow feature taskmaster at all
like don't you think antonia drakov
is still an interesting character it
could have just been her own character
without having to
pile on the taskmaster identity i mean
i mean if if there wasn't taskmaster in
this movie what marvel villain
would be the villain like it would just
be this this black widow adventure with
all like original characters which
would be fine but at the same time what
would be the draw to get people into
theaters i think they needed some type
of like what's the name
like we need a big name it's taskmaster
and so
you know they they just you know her
name is antonia
because uh the original taskmaster in
the comics is anthony masters
this is obviously a gender flipped
version of
the character so like you know yeah i
hear that and that is
unfortunately something that i feel like
marvel studios thinks they need for
these movies but i don't know you just
tell me you're making a black widow
movie i'll go watch it
right like it's true i think that's a
fear
that marvel has and they don't need to
have anymore because their brand is so
valuable
i think like compare this to captain
america the winter soldier right so the
winner soldier seems like the villain of
the movie
and then it's revealed as it is in the
comics to be bucky and the real villain
is alexander pierce like can't you just
like say the villain's going to be
one of these other like either whether
it's red guardian or something like that
or yelena bulova is going to be the
villain of it but then they like team up
and then face drakov
like i don't know if you need taskmaster
for that i don't know if you need that
draw elaine beloved is a fascinating
character
and if you just like market this film
and say elena beloveda is going to be in
it most people can be like oh the rival
because a lot of times in the comics
they're not working together
so similarly like i think they could
have just done that i don't know if we
need
i mean not to say i i do think
taskmaster could very easily be just a
title that is passed on to someone else
in the future i'm not saying we're done
with taskmaster
i don't entirely hate it as much as some
people are saying online but i i do
think
i hope marvel walks away from this
saying like we don't need
a super villain in every title that we
put on the poster of the movie
characters conflicts can just be more
internal or more
drawn with like lesser faces from their
pasts um
i don't know that's just me if you have
a good enough storyteller you don't need
big you know names to to to to drop you
people to your film and i'm not saying
that
the people who made black widow aren't
good storytellers so this is a very good
great story
um but it's just like like you said like
i'm just uh you know co-signing what you
said like yeah it doesn't really matter
you don't need a task master we don't
need a big
villain we just need to see our favorite
heroes going through some type of
struggle and then overcoming it so like
we do
as long as that's there it's okay like
taskmaster didn't need to be in this
movie at all like
the same taskmaster for something else
something more i feel more appropriate
for
the character's um skill set because i
feel like
there's a good chunk of this movie where
we don't see taskmaster at all
he's just like or she's just like off
screen completely so i was like
they could have just given her more to
do i don't know well and like
the they could have given her more
agency as well like i know part of the
theme of the movie is that drakov has
like these people programmed right
but like by making her he said i have to
put the chip in the back of her head and
then you see it from her point of view
it's like this terminatory algorithm
uh that honestly feels like part of iron
man's tech and we already saw that in a
movie as well
like why not just make her so pissed off
at what natasha did to her that she has
spent her life dedicating
mirroring the avengers and it is
something like what tony masters has
which is like photographic reflexes
like it's not something to where her
brain had to be programmed
uh it's something to wear like it's just
another example of how
you know this movie does kind of look at
how all these characters are
not necessarily the best people you know
they leave destruction and awake and i
just thought it was such an interesting
choice
to have natasha mostly unremorseful
for killing this girl when she's like
look it was the mission it had to be
done to get to drakov
like that's fascinating like just yeah
like at that moment when loki said
drakov's daughter and avengers
like she looked genuinely guilty when he
said that and then at the end of that
scene she goes thank you for cooperation
and kind of struts away
like this is someone who is a
cold-blooded killer in her past
she does have some redner ledges she's
trying to clear it but specifically each
of these things
i don't know how apologetic she is so to
explore that side of her character
i think it'd be fascinating to force her
to be accountable for that
by making antonia drakov such a fearsome
threat who has some true emotional
stakes and instead all we really got was
natasha just going
i'm sorry kind of apologizing in her ear
at the end i don't know it wasn't enough
for me was not enough for me
no it definitely wasn't and like you
know the the the character of antonio
drakov for me
just seems very hollow it just seems
like it's just very a blank slate like i
don't really in like i guess that's like
she didn't even blink she's just a
mannequin
she's a man off my eyelids
but no like she just seemed like very
just like i'm not really a person and
like they could have like you said
made a i had a really good opportunity
to to have her just filled with rage
it's like i just want to get better so i
can just kill that chick and try to kill
me
and like you know just and like you know
just be like better and stronger so that
i'll never be in this
weak vulnerable position again like that
would have been a lot more interesting
than
i'm just this victim of this explosion
and now i work for my dad who can't get
over it
i don't know yeah um but let's move on
and talk about val
in this i just the fact that val showed
up in this very surprising to me
um because it's the first time that
we've seen something that showed up in a
disney plush show first
show up in a movie right and but we have
to acknowledge that black widow was
supposed to come out months before the
falcon the winter soldier that was
marvel's original timeline
so is that going to be the case would
that have changed anything seeing
val show up in black widow before we saw
her with john walker
and the falcon winner soldier hmm i
don't think so
i think that these are two very separate
scenes that could have happened
either way first like i feel like i feel
like the the way that we got it was
the best way because like that those
footsteps in of the winter soldier like
who is this and then like it's the slow
reveal i was like oh my god that was
amazing i like that reveal
so like to have but like you know we did
have the her
uh what's it called blowing her nose at
the at the grave so like that would have
been fun too
but yeah i don't think anything really
changes um in terms of like the order
that we see it i think that it's just
like this
has always been the plan for uh you know
val
for marvel and they're just like all
right i guess we'll just do it this way
because of the pandemic
but like what do you think well i i
wonder
like in when we saw him in the falcon
winner soldier we got her full name
so we would have had to do more like
guess work and then instead it would
have just been like
julie louie dreyfus what
like that would have hit harder with
more people i think watched but
uh but i yeah i think i i agree with you
like is these could have come in either
order and i think that's why they did it
this way see
i wonder if like if if if the orders
were reversed
if people would think that val was
working more with nick fury
um because like she does have that
connection with nick fury in the
comments right but since we got the
in the winter soldier first and we know
that
val's sort of not really the best person
because she's
working with a psychopath first of all
and she's manipulating a psychopath
so it's just like if we got you know
the hey i know you're sad but like
here's you know
kill clint in all this stuff we would
have been like wait a minute
well that's kind of weird but like she
wasn't on vormir so maybe she's just
like mistaken right
and like you know all this stuff so like
i feel like our perceptions of who val
is as a person might be different if we
got those uh
differently i agree different orders
that's a good point empty the
introduction we got in falcon winter
soldier was such a great introduction to
the character i think that is better of
an introduction than this scene is who
knows what they reshot and might have
reconfigured though
um so i'm happy with the way she is in
the mcu
um but i want to ask you so the final
shot of the movie before we see natasha
with her
shorter blonde hair is like she seems
like she's about to have to face ross
and all of his men how did you how did
she get away from him and what she was
what was she doing during those two
weeks hmm
that's actually a good question because
like they sort of just drove past her at
the end it's like oh
hey natasha i'm just gonna go see what's
going on with this crash
um i don't know how she escaped ross at
the end i mean
she's sort of just i feel like she just
snuck away
and just like all right just gonna she's
gonna leave him again
and like because like there was a lot of
destruction and people didn't really
know what was going on so they just they
sort of just focus on like on like all
right let's just clear the debris
maybe get some intel from this red room
whatever and they're just like whatever
i mean
we'll find natasha one of these days
it's whatever like she's gonna sneak
past us anyway
so like i think as she sifted through
the wreckage and found one of those
masks and she slipped it back
[Laughter]
it's just like it's like torn up she's
just like people get together like all
right hold on
you have like half of it flickering on
the face it just looks like that other
shield agent that was helping
uh or a furious guy just like what's
wrong with you johnson
i'm fine i'm
[Laughter]
confirmed we solved it question answered
you're welcome um so empty do you think
red guardian could have ever faced an
alternate version of captain america
like isaiah bradley cause there's no way
he faced steve rogers but could he yes
that is bradley that was one of the most
like really
like wait wait a minute what is he
talking about type of scenario like a
situation when he was talking about
a bragging about his fight with captain
america in prison cause like the
timelines don't match up and so that got
me thinking
what if it is steve rogers from like go
doing his old time heist thingy like any
runs across red guardians like
i feel like that's something kevin feige
would do as like a little teaser like
you know what
captain like steve rogers he's got his
own thing in time
we haven't explored yet so like he's a
little crumb that we're leaving behind
so
that would be really fun but isaiah
braley does is really fun as well what
do you think
i i think red guardian was probably just
lying i think that was the concept
he was just telling these prison stories
to try to talk himself up you know
like how much of a badass he is uh he's
like boastful loki and that loki's scene
you know it's just like
straight up um but i want i would love
to see red guardian face some other
version of captain america whether
that's i think isaiah bradley he was
like a korean war fighter
and then red guardian was kind of active
in the 80s so i don't know if the
timeline really matches up there
uh isaiah bradley at that point was
either retired or no he was in prison
right for like 30 years something
horrible
uh yeah yeah so um but i i would love to
see especially if there's like some kind
of multiverse what-if scenario to see
red guardian fighting some version of
captain i would love to see like you
just brought up red guardian boastful
loki hanging out
like that would be so funny we're just
lying to each other
oh yeah yeah yeah well uh well i was
there i was there uh
right when thanos snapped i was hiding
behind one of those wakandan trees i saw
him do it and he looked at me and he's
like uh oh and he tried to study but i
didn't dust i resisted the dusting
that's how strong i am
and thanos he's like oh and he snuck
away because you're so afraid
he flew the phantom's copter away yeah
he should have got to go
[Laughter]
so we have a couple other videos we want
to make about black widow but that will
be it for this episode of inside marvel
so don't forget to check out uh
all the other merch options we talked
about the black widow merch
uh that's gonna be a limited amount of
time and of course all of our loki
options
and newrockstarsmerch.com follow mt at
mastertainment follow me at ea boss
follow new rock stars subscribe to
inside marvel wherever you get your
podcast thank you for watching and we'll
close with our favorite moment from the
film
hey thank you
[Music]
you